this is why OIC can be a slippery [Music]
slope hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
Kitchen today I'm going to be looking at the Tik
Tok trend of OIC users posting their what I in a
day and I'm going to be reviewing The Good The Bad
and The possibly super dangerous we're going to
go back to Old School aby's kitchen review days
so heads up here I will be mentioning calories
and also very low calorie diets and if you're
not subscribed definitely hit that subscribe
button and check out my description for my
free Hunger crushing combo ebook Okay so I have
talked a lot about OIC on my channel including
chronicling a real life Journey with my friend
and manager Ginger and aside from the risk of
abuse one of the main physical health concerns
that experts have with OIC is the risk of actual
malnutrition nurition so glb1 agonists work by
suppressing appetite and reducing the rate at
which food exits the stomach so that alone can
result in some significant weight loss but they
also can cause a lot of severe nausea which can
further reduce people's desire to eat so the risk
here is that folks might end up being put on too
aggressive of a dose the drug may actually work
too well patients eat far too little they lose
weight way too fast including metabolic muscle
mass and they actually become Mal nourished now
we don't have a lot of research on the likelihood
of malnutrition but the New York Times recently
reported on the concerns of weight loss doctors
that in some cases the drug can take dieting way
too far ultimately weight loss always comes down
to a calorie deficit and while zic makes staying
in a calorie deficit a lot easier because your
hunger cues are suppressed you still actually
need to make sure that you're meeting your basic
nutrition needs even if the cues are no longer
there there so safe effective weight loss rates
are generally around5 to 1% of body weight per
week likely at the higher end when on OIC but
this equates to around a 20% calorie deficit give
or take which is a safe cut to prevent a good
chunk of that weight coming from lean body mass
like muscle or bone now this is what we recommend
with any non-pharma weight loss diet but a lot
of folks on OIC will push that deficit much much
further and that explains means one stud's finding
that within a year of oepic treatment participants
lost almost as much lean mass as they did Fat
MK I spoke with a number of my colleagues who
work with oepic patients plus Eric Williamson of
unlocked Fitness and Nutrition and most said that
they try not to go below 14 to 1500 calories while
ultimately prioritizing protein at every single
meal plus snacks re suggest that fat loss can
increase threefold when going from 10 to 15% of
calories from protein to around 20 to 30% and the
greater the deficit the more protein that you're
going to need to stimulate muscle synthesis so
some of my colleagues actually suggest that when
calories get very low their clients are aiming
for around 30 to 40% of calories from protein so
to put that into perspective for you guys if you
are consuming 1,400 calories on OIC you're aiming
for 105 to 140 gram of protein per day spread out
in 20 35 G doses throughout the day to maximize
muscle preservation all that said one of the
nice things about OIC is that you don't have
to obsess about calories anymore so I wouldn't
recommend counting and tracking everything you
put into your mouth but rather simply focusing
on hitting those protein goals give or take
complimenting that protein with moderate portions
of fiber carbs and fat and letting your appetite
guide the rest on that note let's take a look at
some EX examples of what iena day on OIC videos
[Music]
online okay first of all lemon water does
not boost your immune system just want to
get that out of the way but second the
protein shake is a really great start
but 130 calories or so for breakfast with
no fruits or veg is kind kind of a missed
opportunity to sneak in extra fiber
and antioxidants also in the next few
months I may or may not have a better
tasting recommendation for you just
saying okay this meal looks super balanced we
got tons of protein in The Omelette healthy
fats and fiber in the avocado and fiber
carbs in the whole grain toast that said
she probably only got around 15 g of protein
just based on how much she ate so to bump
that up I would consider doing my omelettes
with one to two whole eggs and the rest egg
[Music]
whites okay this looks so delicious and I love
that ozenc has helped her find a way to enjoy rice
in moderation I also love that she did one roll
with rice and the other one with cucumber which
helps to contribute a little more antioxidants
and fiber that said without knowing anything
about this woman's metabolic needs I would say
this is likely too aggressive of a cut to meet
overall nutrient needs which makes it really
really hard to meet your protein needs because
the calories were probably in the neighborhood of
like 1,00 were're only able to get around 50 g of
protein team we ideally would want at least two
or even three times that amount so this is where
I would be cautiously working with my doctor
to adjust the dose to ensure that we can reach
that goldilock spot where your appetite allows
you to achieve that 20 to 25% calorie deficit
while still being adequate enough to not become
malnourished okay moving on here's what I eat in
a day 107 lbs down with PCOS so I start off my day
every day now with these Mighty turmeric and no
joke Ginger from Trader Joe's of course a Chobani
complete 20 g of protein and then I was feeling a
little off yesterday so I had half looks amazing
I mean I'm not sure what the purpose of the spicy
shots are for maybe for digestion and or immune
support I don't know but regardless I love that
we've got some Fiber here and we've got a solid
20 something dose of protein to start the day I
had some chicken te p marala with spinach and
rice 42 G Core Power always this is my kind of
meal here I mean people think you can't have rice
if you have PCOS or insulin resistance but no you
just got to dress up those naked carbs like she
did with protein fiber and fat now I'm not sure
if the protein shake was served with the chicken
masala but if she could space it out a few hours
and have it as a snack it would increase the
utilization of that protein for muscle protein
synthesis since there's already like a fully
utilized load with the chicken and then dinner was
this delicious zucchini and cotia chicken these
jalapeno poppers that my friend made that look
like mummies 10 out of 10 had my Stanley snack
tray and enjoyed a few like I said glasses of
wine again amazing and totally non-restrictive
it seems like this creator has found like her
goldilock dose where she can lose or maintain her
significant weight loss while still meeting her
nutrient needs I'm estimating around 150 gram
of protein give or take depending on how much
she ate so I would not be particularly worried
about malnutrition or muscle wasting with an
oepic diet like this and now I like really
want a mummy wrapped jalapeno popper okay
[Music] next [Music]
okay looks good though would probably be
ideal to add some produce to this meal to
bump up the fiber but protein looks great
there's probably around 25 to 40 grams of
protein depending on how much collagen
she added though FYI collagen protein
isn't the most bioavailable protein since it's
missing tryptophan but thankfully the eggs and
the turkey bacon helped compensate for that so
this looks good hey that's pretty [Music] good
another great example of a full protein dose for
muscle preservation with around 30 gr of [Music]
protein okay so we got 24 g of protein plus
some carbs and like a tiny tiny tiny bit of
EG but Pro tip if you like these kind of
microwave meals Chuck a few big handfuls
of spinach into a bowl before you microwave
just to get in some extra fiber and [Music]
micronutrients okay so I'm not sure how these
snacks are like spaced out in her day but
ideally we give at least 2 hours between protein
doses I'm going to call them so like she could
do the protein water and the built bar as one
meal and the fake bar and the premier protein
shake as another that said even if you don't
it's not like that protein just gets lost or
immediately turns into fat when you are still
in a calorie deficit I'm just talking optimal
scenario considering the risk of muscle loss on
OIC so yeah there's a lot of protein here maybe
150 gr even but because virtually all the foods
are Ultra processed protein snacks that protein
is kind of coming in at the expense of basically
everything else we're lacking fiber there's
virtually no healthy fats and there's probably a
lot of additives sodium and artificial sweeteners
which may be totally fine in the short run but
probably not so easy on the gut long term that
said a lot of folks need to lean on convenience
Foods while on OIC because when your appetite is
so suppressed you kind of lack the inspiration
to cook for yourself food really does become
just fuel for some folks so feeding yourself just
like a bunch of protein shakes or bars rather than
cooking a whole food meal may actually be a true
Act of self-care so like I said I would just try
to meet her where she is with a few little simple
tweaks like the spinach hack just to sneak in some
extra micronutrients and fiber without adding a
lot more worker stress and on that note whether
you're on OIC or really any other weight loss
journey I do hope this serves as a good reminder
that less is not necessarily more even if your
hunger cues are unnaturally low on o senic we
still need to make the effort to meet our nutrient
needs both our macros and our micros plus other
beneficial compounds like fiber and probiotics and
failing to do so will likely cause way more harm
than good and that's all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment below
and I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye